قال مثلا امريكيون ان واشنطن تضع اللمسات
الاخيره على خطط لتزويج اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ الباتريوت للدفاع الجوي وان تلك
الخطط تنتظر موافقه وزير الدفاع ثم توقيع
الرئيس بايدا عليها قرر امريكي توعدت
روسيا بالرد عليه مشدره على ان اي جهه
الاوكرانيه ستحصل على تلك المنظمات ستكون
هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه 3 مصارعه
التي رفضت اتخاذها مرارا متعادله بالتزام
داخل الناتو يحصرها في دونه الاعضاء وماذا
تعنيه لمعادلات الحرب الاستراتيجيه
وكيف تتلقى موسكو هذه الخطوه وما النتائج
المترتبه على اعلان الكرملين استهداف
المنظومه الدفاعيه الامريكيه باعتبارها
هدفا مشروعا وما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله
لهذه الخطوه على مسار التسويه في ضو اعلان
الغربيه عن فشل جهود تهيئه مسار التفوضي
مع موسكو بشان الحرب
[موسيقى]
قرار تردد في الولايات المتحده طويلا
لكنها اليوم باتت اقرب من اي وقت مضى
لاتخذه واشنطن تستعد لتزويد كيف بمنظومه
الدفاعيه ذائعه الصيد اليد الطول في
التصدي للصواريخ الطرف المقابل والطرف
المقابل هنا هو روسيا التي هدرت بان ما
سيتم تسليمه لاوكرانيين من هذه المنظومه
لا يمكن تصنيفه سوى في خانه التصعيد
الميداني ولغه السلاح في وقت تشهد في جهود
ترمي لتهيئه المناخ لتسويه الماء تشهد
التعسرا ان لم يكن فشلا بشكل واضح
ليست الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحدها من
يتجه لتعزيز مساعدته لاوكرانيا فبالتزامل
مع اعلان الاتحاد الاوروبي اليه لتنسيق
المساعدات الموجهه الى كيف اعلنت الخارجيه
البريطانيه في تغريده ان رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني اعلن حزمه دعم للدفاع الجوي
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50 مليون جنيه استرلي
واضافت الخارجيه البريطانيه ان حزمه
المساعده الجديده لاوكرانيا تتالف من مئه
وخمسه وعشرين مدفعا مضاده للطائرات
والتكنولوجيا لمواجهه المسيره الايرانيه
روسيا تلقت الرساله التي صدرت من جهه
الغربيه عده بمضمون واحد في نهايه المطاف
قامت بالرد على لسان نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي لمتر ميدفيدف مدفيدف قال
انه اذا قام نيته حسب ما لما حل امين
العام لحلف الاطلسي ستول تمبرج بيت تزويدي
من وصفهم بالمتعصبين في كيابه بمنظمات مع
عناصر من قوات النيترو فسيصبحون على الفور
هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
السدره السياسي الروسي من واشنطن الدكتور
المدير التنفي
الشؤون الدوليه مركز الدراسات عبر الاطلسي
ومن عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه عميد اللواء فايز
الدويري
نريد ان نعرف معلومات اكثر عن هذه
المنظومه باتريوت التي تحتاج الى تدريب
هي طبعا اكبر سلاح امريكي متقدم سيقدم الى
اوكرانيا ما الذي ستغيره هذه المنظومه اذا
انضمت الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
يعني لقد تم تقديم العديد من الصواريخ
المضاده تقريبا سبعه انظمه بما فيها نظام
باتريوت منها تقريبا اربعه انظمه قصيره
طويله المدى ومنها ثلاثه انظمه قصيره
المدى الاولى متوسطه
تقريبا يعتبر نظام دفاع جوي هو انتاج
مشترك
والله الباتريوت واعتمددته الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في الدفاع عن البيت
الابيض والبنتاجون وتم الاقرار وتم
التسليم هناك نظام ايرس كذلك تقريبا
انا ما اقول ان هذا النظام تقريبا تم
تزويد انظمه مكافئه بدرجه لا تقل عن 90%
لهذا النظام لكن هذا النظام ميزته انه
ياخذ شهره بسبب تاريخي تلك الامر المنتجات
كانت في القرن ال 21 وهذا منتج قبل ذلك
باكثر من 30 عاما ومر بثلاثه مراحل تطور
هذه المناص يوجد عليها 19 صاروخ الرادار
يغطي دائره 100 كيلو متر يستطيع ان تتبع
في المعركه ام لا هل سيغير في المعركه ام
لا يغير
الايجابي ليست اسود وابيض
التغيير يعتمد على عوامل كذلك ما هي
الاعداد التي سترسم المنصه الواحده 16
صاروخ تعمل ضمن دائره لغايه فاعليه 40
كيلومتر هل سيتم ارسال اكثر من مرصه وكيف
يمكن توظيف وادماجها لتعمل بالتناغم مع
ايرس ومعنى شمس وبالتالي هي لابد ان تحدث
تغيير ولكن هذا التغيير حجمه مرتبط
بالاعداد وكفاءه العاملين الذين سيتم
تدريبهم في قاعده امريكيه في المانيا هذا
السلاح كان يعتبر خط احمر الان تم تقديمه
او الموافقه
وهذا هو يطرح سؤال عن التوقيت وهنا اتوجه
الى ضيفه
ترددت واشنطن طويلا همم قبل مجرد الحديث
حتى عن تزويده اوكرانيه بالصواريخ
لماذا الان اذا لماذا يجري الحديث الان
يعني حتى جوكر بي منسق الاتصال بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي حينما تحدث عن
الموضوع لم ينفه لم ينفي مسرح به مسرورون
امريكيون لسي ان ان ونقلته اي بي وما شبه
لكن هو قال انه ليست في هذه المرحله فاذا
كان القرار اتخذ او على وشك الاتخاذ
فلماذا الان
هناك
اولا طبيعه الاعتداءات الروسيه حيث لدينا
هذا الاعتداءات بلا هواء دالي هنا تحتيها
المدنيه
واقرار في واشنطن بان هذا لا يمكن السماح
باستمرار هذا اولا
كروي» اعتقد ان هناك تنامي في الثقه تجاه
قياده الرئيس الاوكرانيازلنسكي وفي طبيعه
العلاقه وتفاعل بين كيف واشنطن لم يعد
هناك المخاوف التي سادت في بدايه الاشتياح
حول المدى الذي تصل اليه اوكرانيا وهل
تتخذ الخطوات بحيث تكون مستفزه هناك
اجراءات اتخذتها اوكرانيا لم توافق عليها
واشنطن على سبيل المثال قتل الشخصيه في
موسكو ولكن بصوره عامه هناك فهم وتفهم لي
ان هذه التجهيزات التي توفرها واشنطن تحطم
على كيف احتراما المخاوف الامريكيه عند
استخدامها هناك واقعيه في فهم واشنطن بان
بوتن ليس في عقليه تسمح له بان يوقف هذا
الاداريه لروسيا على جميع المشاهدين ان
يدركوا مدى ضعف في هذا القائد بوتن وخطائه
في الحسابات
وحساباته
نتحدث هنا عن حسابات المعركه في ضوء هذه
التصريحات الامريكيه وهنا اتوجه من موسكو
ميدفيد في قارئ نادي المنظومه ستستهدف ومن
يعمل عليها سيستهدف ومن وصفهم بالمتعصبين
في اوكرانيا سيستهدفون بمجرد دخولها
اوكرانيا ما مصدر القلق الذي تمثله هذه
المنظومه
تحياتي لك والاساده المشاهدين وليدافيك
الكريمين انا لا اعتقد بان موسكو تشعر
بقلق جرار هذه الخطوه او هذه الخطوه او
القرار الذي يمكن ان يتخذ خلال الايام
القليله القادمه لعده اسباب اولها ان هذه
الصواريخ بات كما يقول الخبراء العسكريون
شبيه جدا بالصواريخ اس 300 حتى بانواع
بتريوت»
وكيف يمكن مواجهتها في اوكرانيا هذا اولا
ثانيا طبعا في حاله اذا تم او كانت تطورات
قد ادت الى فشل الاستخدام هذه الصواريخ
الاتيه واذا تم تزويد اوكراني بدفاعات
محدوده منها فان هذا سنعكس سلبا على سمعه
العسكريه الامريكيه لان كل طرف هو بيبقى
في ذلك طبعا الولايات المتحده تاخذ بعالج
كبار تداعيات استخدام هذه الاسلحه واذا ما
فشلت فينا هذا طبعا يدعك السلبا على
الولايات المتحده نفسها
وكذلك هناك نقاط الضعف همم لهذه الصواريخ
كما يقول الخبراء العسكريون وهي انها لا
تتعامل مع اهدافهم همم تحلق على على
ارتفاعات منخفضه جدا فيما ان نز- اا انظمه
شمس قادره على ذلك وبالتالي يعني روسيا
ليس لديها اي قلق واي مخاوف من همم ورود
هذه الصواريخ الى اوكرانيا همم علما بان
التدريب وتحضير الصواريخ والمنظمات
للعمل والمشاركه في العمليات القتاليه لن
يبدا الا بعض بدعه اشهر من وصولها الى
اوراديا لكن هنالك تدريب الامريكي تدريب
الان لهم في المانيا لكن عليه الاحوال هذه
خطه همم هل هي في لمساته الاخيره امامنا
الاداره الامريكيه تتريث قبل الاقدام على
تنفيذ قرارها هذا سؤال نجم عن تصريحات
لمنسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جونكاربي الذي قال
لا يمكننا تاكيد التقارير بشان تقديم
النظام باترير الى اوكرانيا خلال الحزمه
المقبله
للمساعده
عد مره اخرى الى ضيفه فايز الدويري وكنت
تتحدث عن الفروق بين هذه المنظومه ومنظومه
الموجوده بالفعل لدى همم الاوكرانيين
وتحدث
من موسكو عن همم 300 التي تقوم تقريبا
بنفس المهمه هل هل اضافتها لصراع له بعد
نفسي اكثر منه بعد ميداني
لا هي لا هي لها بعد نفسي ولا بعد ميداني
يعني لا استطيع قد اختلف مع ضيفك من موسكو
قد لا استطيع ان اقارنها بي اس 300 تتفوق
بصوره صارخه جدا على اس 300 ولكنها لا
توازي اس 400 لماذا بسبب فروق تقنيه اس 4
يغطي اربعه مدائعيات همم من 400 250 250
و125 كلم اذا دعني اقول لا اقارنه بين 300
تقدم اضافه نوعيه في البعد الميداني وتقدم
اضافه بالبعد الرمزي ولكن همم اشار ضيفك
انها لا تتعامل مع الاهداف المنفذه نعم
عمل الدفاع الجوي هو عمل تراكمي هناك
ثلاثه منظومات تم تقديمها تعمل في المدى
القصيره ستينجر
ليس الارتفاعات المنخفضه الهدف هو
الصواريخ الروسيه التي تدمر البنيه
التحتيه الاساسيه الاوكرانيه والتي تاتي
اصلا من من خارج اوكرانيا وليس من داخل
اوكراني وليس من القوات الروسيه الموجوده
في اوكرانيا
يا سيدي مشكله هذه الصواريخ سواء ناس همم
ناس امس او الباتريوت في التكلفه القائد
الاساسيه لاستخدام الدفاع الجوي يجب ان
تطلق صاروخين على كل هدف اذا كان الهدف
صاروخ او طائره مسيره التكلفه
باك 1 مليون دولار لكل صاروخ باك باك 3
الهدف الجوي تكلفه الصواريخ المطلقه من
ثلاثه الى اربعه مليون دولار اذا كان
الهدف طائره طائره شاهد 129
تكريفتها 20,000 دولار فانت تقابلها ولكن
في هذا المقارنه قد يرفضها البعض لانه
يعتبر ان هذه الطائره نجحت في مهاجمه
الهدف فالان تصبح المقارنه بين تكلفه
الصواريخ
المنشاه وتع داعيات تدمير المنشاه خاصه
اذا كانت محطات كهرباء كهربائيه
تقدم اضافه نوعيه في البعدين النفسي
والمادي تقدم اضافه نوعيه لاسمه في
الارتفاعات الكبيره والصواريخ التي تاتي
من خارج اوكرانيا لكن ربما لا تقدم نفس
الاضافه للطائرات المسيره رخيصه الثمن هذا
ما تقول اللواء فايز الدويري ادوار جوزيف
همم ما الذي تقدمه اذا يعني لماذا تحرص
الاداره الامريكيه على التعجل الان في
اقرار هذه المنظومه وارسالها الى همم الى
اوكرانيا اذا كان لن تتمكن مثلا او لن
ستكون التكلفه باهظه في مواجهه الخطر
الاكبر وهو الطائرات المسيره التي قال همم
كانها مسؤوله عن هدم وتدمير ثلث البنيه
التحتيه في مدينه من ضمن المدن الاخرانيه
واضح
صغيره
ويتم الدفاع عنها من خلال تجهيزات اخرى
تمتلكها اوكرانيا وهي عاده محموله يمكن
للجنود ان يحملوها بانفسهم
لصواريخ اكثر تاثيرا وليس من اجل طائرات
مسيره بصوره اساسيه
سبب
اخرى
الموضوع هو اخطا انت حسابه وحسب انه يمكن
ان نستخدم الشتاء لصالحه سواء في اوكرانيا
او من خلال اضعاف الدعم الامريكي
والاوروبي للحرب مره اخرى تبين ان هذا لم
يكن صحيحا مره اخرى اخطا في حساباته
الولايات المتحده تستعجل الموافقه على
ارسالها هذا النظام البيتشوت من اجل
تاثيره في ميدان المعركه للتصدي
للاعتداءات الروسيه ولنقل الرساله بكل
وضوح الى بوتن انه سوف لن يتمكن من اثنائه
الولايات المتحده وادعو الاوروبيه في دعم
اوكرانيا في هذا الاعتداء الذي لم يكن له
مبرر
نقل هذه التكنولوجيا الى اوكرانيا قلت انه
ليس محل مخاوف الان لانه تم بناء الثقه
بين الجانبين لكن همم حسب الخبره ايضا فان
التشغيل هذه المنظومه يحتاج الى جنود
امريكيين على الارض هل الوقت همم هل حان
الوقت الان لوجود جنود امريكيين على الارض
هل هنالك حساب لهذه المخاطر اما انه سيتم
تدريب الاوكرانيين في قاعده المانيه ااه
مهما مهما استغرق هذا التدريب من وقت حتى
يكون هم جاهزين بانفسهم لادارتها وتشغيلها
القرار
الثاني سوف لن يكون هناك وجودا لجنود
امريكيين على ارض المعركه
لقد استبعد الرئيس الامريكي ذلك سوف يدرب
الجنود الاوكرانيون في المانيا على تشغيل
واداراتها هذه المنظومه ليس هناك سبب يدعو
الى القلاق بالنسبه الى نوعيه التدريب
الذي يتلقونه وكذلك قدرتهم على تنفيذه
واستخدام الموضوع بطريقه فعاله لقد راينا
كيف ان القوات الاوكرانيه
وبشكل سريع تكيفت مع استخدام المدفعيه
الامريكيه المتطوره ولاسيهما منظومه هاي
مارس اذا تدربوا سريعا واعرف كيفيه
استخدامها ويستخدمون بطريقه فعاله وهم
يتصدعون من خلالها للاعتداءات الروسيه
طبعا الولايات المتحده سوف توفروا
التدريبا عاليه الجوده للجنود الاوكرانيين
حتى يستخدمهم منظومه بطريقه نفسها
هذا التهديدف باستهدف هذه المطلوبه ومن
سيعملوا عليها ان هذه التهديلات الروسيه
يعني نسمعها منذ بدايه الحرب وكما تعلم
فان الاسلحه الغربيه همم ذهبت بمنتهى
السهوله الى ايدي الاخرانيين وغيرت مسار
الحرب باعترافيا
نعم انا اعتقد بان هذه المصداقيه ومد
فيديو جاد في مثل هذه التصريحات علما بان
روسيا طبعا
ضد اي تواجد اجنبي على اراضي اوكرانيا
سواء كانوا مثلا مدربيننا الذين يمكن ان
يدربوا عناصر الجيش الاوكراني على الارض
مباشره في اوكرانيا وليس فقط في المانيا
يعني ما الذي يجعلهم قادرين على مانع
الباتريوت اذا لم يكونوا قادرين على مانع
والنسامس وغيره
هناك اصوات تتعالى من الاوساط العسكريه
تقريبا يوميا وتحذر من ضروره التركيز على
هذا الموضوع واستهدافهم قبل ان تصل الى
ساحه القتال ولكن طبعا لاسباب ما ااا
لا تكشف عنها المصادر العسكريه الروسيه
طبعا ليس كل الاسلحه او معظم الاسلحه التي
تصل الى هناك ربما تصل مباشره الى الجيش
الاوكراني الرغبه ذلك فانه هناك استهدافات
همم بعض العتاب والاسلحه همم اثناء طريقها
الى اوكرانيا على الارض الاوكرانيه طبعا
لان روسيا لا يمكن ان تستخدمه وتستهدف اي
اهداف خارج حدود اوكرانيا مع ذلك معلومات
صحيحه جدا بهذا الشان ونحن نكتفي بما
لدينا من معلومات رسميه فقط
اه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا يبقيني دروب من موسكو
الكاتب المحارب السياسيه واشكر ضيفي من
واشنطن الدكتور
الدوليه لمركز الدراسات عبر الاطلسي ومن
عمان اشكر اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكريه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي في قراءه اخرى لخبر
الجديد حتى ذلك
[موسيقى]